madame monsieur bonsoir au lendemain de
l'intervention d'alain juppé les forces
de l'ordre sont donc intervenus ce matin
à l'église saint bernard
environ un millier de gendarmes mobiles
et de crs qui ont forcé vers 19h45 la
porte de l'église savoir saint bernard
pour s'emparer des sans papiers alors
50e jour de grève de la faim les
grévistes ont été évacués vers des
hôpitaux militaires
les autres ont pris la direction du
centre de rétention de vincennes où leur
cas devrait être examiné le reste il de
cette matinée musclée pascal douce est
bon et valérie fournier jusqu'au bout
ils tentent de faire barrage à l'assaut
des forces de l'ordre eux qui campe avec
les réfugiés depuis des semaines font un
rempart de leurs corps
esquive les coupes gêne leur progression
mais les gendarmes mobiles arriveront à
leurs fins en 20 minutes
les portes de l'église mettront moins de
temps à résister pendant ce temps à
l'intérieur une barricade de chaises et
ériger à la hâte
elle ne tiendra que quelques minutes
8h15 les gendarmes mobiles entre
simultanément par les deux portes le
curé doit interrompre la célébration
qu'il dirigeait est-ce que vous
ressentez l'actuellement ou bien j'en ai
pleuré
et
j'ai un peu honte sur vous pour nous
l'issue est désormais certaine alors les
nerfs lâchent à boubacar diop délégués
des familles doit calmer c'est trop mais
comme les autres il refuse de bouger
alors l'évacuation prend un tour plus
musclée à moins de 100 mètres de là des
paris vient d'autres venus de plus loin
et des habitants du quartier à courre
tentent de rejoindre ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur et les gendarmes mobiles
lance des gaz lacrymogènes pour les
repousser
au pied de l'église ceux qui ont dormi
là et qui résistent encore aux forces de
l'ordre leur font signe de venir
pendant ce temps l'évacuation des dix
grévistes de la faim se fait par la
petite porte du presbytère
ils sont dirigés vers les hôpitaux
militaires bégin et persil le professeur
choix de solberg lui sera déloger de
force
contraints d'attendre ici tandis que les
parisiens continuent d'affluer a clamé
leur solidarité mais j'ai vu passer les
enfants dans les cars ben on a quand
même les larmes aux yeux en voyant ça
moi je suis pas fier d'être français
lyon vient de vie sur terre
ils ont entendu la radio débarquer
on arrive à mu potable très vite la
mobilisation s'organise au même moment
devant l'entrée principale
les sans papiers sont emmenés un parent
vers les bus dans le calme mais non sans
appréhension
les familles ont peur d'être séparés
madjiguène cissé porte-parole des
sans-papiers refuse de monter sans son
mari et son enfant
quant à emmanuelle béart et les
conduites avec d'autres sympathisants
vers le commissariat le plus proche
les onze bus vont partir les uns après
les autres vers le centre de rétention
de vincennes
l'opération aura duré trois heures